okay how about a non security talk so
weird it is slightly weird so I've
actually done this talk a couple of
times before and it is sort of a soft
skill talk it's more about career stuff
and I've honestly been really really
surprised at how many people like it not
because I thought it was a bad talk but
because I'm just surprised that so many
of us come here and we do like tech
stuff and then a lot of people actually
interested in some software school stuff
too so look I hope you enjoy this and a
lot of this talk is about my experiences
going from my previous job in a company
called Pfizer through to what I do now
now many of you have probably used
Pfizer products but in case you don't
know who they are they make this and I'm
not saying you use this one per se they
make a lot of different things they make
things like lipitor for cholesterol
zoloft for depression and look at I
think a lot of people think that working
for a company like Pfizer the makers of
viagra would be a lot of fun and there
were there were aspects of it which were
enjoyable I spent 14 years in the
company at total so I couldn't have been
too dramatically bad but one of the
things I found as I was there and I
think a lot of you probably find this in
your careers as well is that you might
be good at what you do so your developer
I went in as a developer and I said are
you know you're quite a good developer
you should stop doing that and become a
manager you know because that's what
you've got to do to progress your career
and I kind of didn't really like that
because I like building stuff but I also
want to feel like I have a career and I
can go somewhere as well and around
about 2009 I decided to start writing a
blog and this was the first blog post I
ever wrote and I want to sort of explain
why I wrote this you know the title you
can see here why online identities a
smart career moves I I felt that when I
was interviewing people for roles and I
couldn't find anything about them
anywhere it just felt a little bit
suspect you know like they give you a CV
and you wouldn't believe it but every
they said they were awesome true story
and they'd give you references and you'd
speak to the references and the
references would go
this person is awesome that's why they
chose you to be the reference this is
the whole point and there was like no
independent verification of what this
person stood for what they've done and
my theory at the time very first blog
posts ever wrote I said I reckon one of
the best ways to make yourself more
marketable as a developer is to have an
active online profile because I'd like
to be able to find information that
backed up the claims that you are making
and I went on and said look I reckon if
you can demonstrate that over time
you've been actively involved in the
areas that you'll see these things so
fantastic about I reckon that's a good
thing because someone else is going to
look at that and go well actually yeah
they're like the CV matches the the
evidence I wasn't wanting to change my
job at the time it's exactly what I said
I said look you know at the time I enjoy
it I was getting a little bit different
franchise we're not doing a lot of dev
stuff anymore but hey you know he works
in a fun place it wasn't too bad and I
made the comment that I don't know if at
some point in time they're not gonna
want me or I'm not gonna want to be
there I don't know what's gonna happen
in the future and I can't just suddenly
decide to do something at the time and
I'm unhappy and as it turns out it took
five years after this before I was very
unhappy and another year after that
before I was gone so if the benefit of
hindsight that was a pretty good time to
actually start writing this blog and
going down the path that I'm going to
talk about here so the place I worked
was part of Sydney it's in the western
side of Sydney called West ride and this
was our our plant so we had a
manufacturing plant there and I worked
in this office down here and my
particular office was all the way down
the bottom just down here in the
basement
without any windows because I'm a tech
person what do I need Windows now my
manager had Windows and the reason he
had Windows
manager Hatcher window seals never there
is always traveling but you got to have
windows so there's a hierarchy and if he
didn't have windows that wouldn't
represent his status within the
organization and a lot of companies are
like this they're not sort of
merit-based who actually needs natural
light because they're actually in the
place it's like what is reflective of
your status no maybe I had a bit of a
window issue today
I often work from a place that doesn't
have any windows at all and this is
literally where I frequently work from
the place called South straight it's an
island near us and I get on my jet ski
and I put my laptop in there and I go
down to the islands about 25 minutes
away which is about the same amount of
time I spent sitting in traffic in
Sydney and I go down here my colleagues
are very often smarter than some of the
ones I had before I don't say a lot
which is good my boy they seem smarter
and then I go home to my wife I ride the
jet ski home it's all very exciting and
this is what it's often like and the
truth is this is very very close to what
it's like so I'm very often out here on
the jet ski and one thing you'll notice
about jet ski everyone on a jet ski is
always happy Google it's true story so
I'll ride the jet ski home and I ride
down our street this is the street we
live on I know it looks difficult
actually the streets here and only wet -
are they anyway be right down here and
we go down to the back of the house so
this is where we live today and behind
the gangplank there you consider a
little a little door and there's a winch
that comes out for trolling you put the
jet ski on and it goes back inside there
and this is literally what life looks
like today and what I really want to
talk about is how that transition
happened and how we have the choices to
live like this today and I'm really
conscious that when I do a talk like
this or when I take photos when I tweet
do things like that there is this
propensity for things to come across the
wrong way you can look like a dick right
and I think each of us are wired
differently some people find this really
abrasive and other people like okay this
is cool and maybe it's a bit
inspirational or a bit
writing and what I'd sort of encourage
you to do over this talk is sort of
think less about this side of things and
more about what you're going to do for
yourselves because this is to try and
give you ideas about how you can
progress and go to other places that you
might want to go and that's not always
necessarily going to be about money or
toys or things like that
but try to keep this in mind what
opportunities are going to make because
all of these things have only come from
things I've done that have actually
opened up doors now all of us are
motivated by different things and you
know as an example many people are
motivated by money that's probably the
reason we go to work in the first place
you know if it was like I could do
anything I want would you be doing
exactly what you're doing now I
certainly wouldn't have been before so
there's important to a lot of people a
lot of people just have jobs that aren't
real good it's got what I felt like very
often that I want to be here this is not
much done anymore a lot of people too
it's just about having more flexibility
with family so a lot of people genuinely
just want to spend more time with their
family a lot of people are now very
happy to finish at five o'clock go home
play with the kids cook dinner do all
that sort of thing go back to work at
9:00 that's fine
we've all got different motivations
different things that are important to
us but I want to sort of talk about how
I made that transition and one of the
first things I did was that blog that
was really the start of it and what I
suggest is that if you're thinking about
starting to have more of an online
persona and more publicity is to
actually talk to your boss about it and
say hey look I got this idea I want to
start writing a blog and I want to talk
to you for a while about why this was
such a good thing not just for what I do
but why I think it's a good thing for
everyone when you write a blog it helps
you do your job better and I'm gonna
give you a few examples this the first
thing that sort of really struck me and
that one of the factors that drove me
towards writing the blog is that every
time I did anything in my professional
capacity
and I got feedback from my colleagues or
my boss or others around me they were
always very nice and that kind of sounds
like a good thing but what I was finding
is that it was filtered I wasn't always
getting candid feedback and part of it
was the difficulty I had is we didn't
have a lot of technical people around us
I was the technical person there are
other people that were more involved in
the business side of things other people
that might be IT pros I was like the dev
guy and they very frequently didn't
understand what I do and in my little
world of the things I did I was the
smartest guy in the room and that's not
a positive place to be you don't grow
and learn a lot when there aren't other
people around pushing you so otherwise
getting us feedback they're like well
you're proposing doing jQuery 2 with
angular on ColdFusion this sounds
fantastic good job let's do it you
didn't understand any of that did you
and this is often the way it was now
when you start writing a blog and you
put something online I don't know if you
guys know this but people on the
Internet can be very direct
right like you get very very unfiltered
very very candid feedback and as I was
writing people would give me very direct
candid feedback they weren't
sugarcoating it they weren't going yeah
whatever you come up with is awesome now
it's not to say that everyone's a dick
there's certainly an aspect of that and
we're gonna see some of that soon
believe me but it was just good organic
feedback from a much broader spectrum of
people than what I could ever get in my
normal job at work I want to give you an
example of sort of some of the things I
was writing and how it helped so back in
2010 I wrote a five part series on
teamcity subversion web deploy nothing
to have security and the reason why I
wrote this was that I was rolling this
out and Pfizer so this was part of sort
of my domain my responsibilities I
wanted to integrate it into CI and
actually have a proper process we didn't
have a good CI process I've never years
teamcity before I honestly had no idea
what I was doing so I thought what I'll
do is I'll write the blog because if I
write the blog first of all
I'm gonna really try and get things
right because I know what people are
like if you get anything wrong so I'm
gonna put a lot more focus into getting
it right and this might seem weird but I
put a lot more effort into it than if I
had to just done it with only an
internal audience I think part of it as
well was I wanted other people to use
his I wanted to create something they
could take away and do the things with
so I had to get the facts right so I
write this series and not only did it
put a lot more effort into it but other
people who knew more about it than me
left me good comments and this was cool
because you're not the smartest person
in the room anymore there's lots of
other people out there that know this
much better than you and this sort of
became one of the things that I had a
reputation for at the time is bit of
ties past now but it allowed me to carve
out a bit of a niche tree like Troy okay
he's the guy that understands how to do
this stuff so I was serving multiple
purposes it was a really good thing to
have done that's a good example on those
lines is things like this so we were
migrating a lot of apps from sort of
traditional hosting into Azure now I
think from memory was about 80 websites
I was like well we keep doing the same
thing over and over again let's automate
it we'll do a bit of PowerShell run some
commands and that will create the web
app in Azure or create the database will
create the accounts it will join
everything up like the magic will happen
I'm going to turn this all into a
massive PowerShell script and I wrote
this blog post I now wrote it whilst I
was doing my job
whilst I was in the office on the
company time and I have no qualms
whatsoever about having done that
because that helped me do that job so
much better than if I hadn't because the
end all saying things like teamcity like
I had to give it a lot of focus I had to
get it right other people chimed in and
gave me feedback this thing worked
really really well it's a fantastic
piece of work and I still look back at
it today as well many of the blog posts
I write incidentally aren't necessarily
for you they so that I can remember what
the hell I've done when I come back to
it later on
in fact when I eventually left the
organisation my handover process my
documentation for things like teamcity
was WWWE hunter calm thought so there it
is there's all the dots and there's some
passwords over here so I'd actually sir
multiple purposes and one of the things
I've found in doing all of this is that
when you work and you publish things
publicly and you do the whole community
thing and you get all the feedback it
starts to give you a lot more
opportunity to leverage things so a lot
of time now people go you know you seem
to be very busy and you do a lot how do
you do all this stuff often you're
seeing the same thing it's just
multiplied over multiple times you know
maybe it's in the news here and then
someone else is talking about it there
and referencing it there it's the same
thing it's the same unit of work it's
just been applied over and over again so
think about that as well like how can i
leverage that effort because if I had a
just sat and Pfizer and built out that
is your PowerShell script and it had of
just done that one thing it would have
been a waste you know doing it the way I
did many people used it and I've got
profile and it contributed towards
things like MVP awards it made a lot of
sense now getting onto the blogging side
of things if you are thinking about
doing a blog I reckon the fastest most
effective way you can get into it today
is to go and get ghost anyone use ghost
here you like it yes very good
okay so ghost is a really really neat
blogging platform things like WordPress
tend to get very clunky they've got lots
of other things it does a gazillion
things that you don't need ghost is nice
because it does blogs you know that's
the focus and more than just guys going
at ghost pro cause 62 cents a day about
19 dollars a month because ghost pros
manage goes so you pay them they host it
they patch it they upgrade if they give
it love and care and they take care of
it all and all you do then is you focus
on writing things now because we are in
the era where you have to have HTTPS
apparently this is what they tell me
going to get CloudFlare as well and you
can get CloudFlare for free and you wrap
CloudFlare around ghost and not only do
you get https and certificates and pad
lots and things you get all of this
caching all the way around the world and
it stops threats and all sorts of
wonderful things so this is great 62
cents a day if you're going to go down
this path is a pretty good investment
probably pretext all those off instantly
if you don't want to
logging I don't reckon you have to know
what to blog about you know you're like
you don't have to have a plan for me
that first blog post I showed you before
I was just like well this is kinda seems
like a good place to start but then I go
through and look at the next blog posts
I created this is the second one it's
around subversion we're doing a lot of
subversion back then little bit here
around Visual Studio 2010 again I saw
this sort of late 2009 era this one on
retrospect I wouldn't necessarily
recommend as being a productive way of
being a better program it is a long term
commitment but you know that the point
was it's like it was something on my
mind let's just write it and as I
started writing I started to focus a
little bit more started writing out
things like software quality this was my
first smack down of another company
interesting fun times
PDC oh nine there's a professional
Developers Conference I didn't get to go
I just read all these different news
pieces about it and thought I could
write something that consolidated this
and put it in one place and every single
one of these has got nothing to do a
security which is the thing that I'm
known for now but it was a starting
point right it's like let me start
writing something let me sort of start
this kind of divergence phase of just
throwing ideas and we'll see where it
starts to focus you don't have to just
write on your own blog as well so there
are plenty of places out there that are
happy for you to write so I was writing
for Red Gate for example you don't get
paid for this but it gets your name
somewhere else it gives you a chance to
write something to publish something to
get a little bit more exposure and again
nothing to do a security also nothing to
a security car no related to security
thank you shared development databases
all of this again was just getting
things out there and getting exposure
now sometimes people say well I'm a
little bit worried that if I do this my
boss is gonna come to me one day and
there's gonna be worried what if you do
get
like what if you become a better person
from your blogging and you leave if your
boss is worried about this this is a
serious problem like honestly if your
boss is worried that hey someone working
for me make it even better at what I'm
paying them to do that's a sign like you
do not want to be there if that's where
you're at with your boss that is not a
productive environment to be in and it
might sound a little bit funny but I've
heard that multiple times over it is
just a ridiculous proposition so the
blog is good there are loads of
opportunities to speak at events as well
so the very first talk I ever did was
this one here and this was at a company
called SSW and it was a user group talk
and it was walking distance from home I
was like literally a few minutes walk
just around the corner so there's a very
very casual talk and that was sort of
the first thing and then I did things
that were a little bit bigger and a
little bit bigger and a little bit
bigger and then six weeks ago I sat in
front of US Congress in Washington DC
which was a lot bigger then a little
years ago talk and I was I was actually
looking at this was putting the slides
segovia they go man those other guys
look so serious don't they and I'm
sitting there with these funny socks I
actually went and got special socks to
go and speak in Congress with they
looked like this
because I didn't want to be too serious
about the whole damn thing and that the
the the thing that on retrospect again
really strikes me is how this was only a
result of that little talk to begin with
and we just kept chipping away and
getting bigger and bigger and being
bigger and for all you guys if you do
want to speak at an event there are lots
of events around that you can go and
submit talks to so for example right now
you can submit to NDC in Oslo this meant
to NDC although right it's like this but
like everything's like multiplied over
several times it is an epic event as
probably still one of my favorite annual
events so if you want to go and speak in
an event like that gun submit a paper
you don't have to have something that
you're the world's expert on you just
have something that's going to be
interesting to other people so events
like that are great there's a lot of
user groups around as well so I still
speak a lot of user groups this was
Copenhagen recently and you know you go
along there and it's a pretty casual
event it's a lot more casual than this
and I sort of spoke for an hour and then
I sat there and just answered questions
for an hour or so and one of the things
actually struck me when I did this event
is I sort of did the talk sit around and
then then we hung around for a few
people and drink beer through I can't
quite remember how long and I remember
people saying this is so cool it's like
you're normal you just hung around and
drunk beer hang around drink beer he
doesn't want to do that and so I said
look we've had other notable people come
along and all they wanted to do is go
talk bang out the door and then they get
into their executive jet or whatever in
they disappear so I reckon doing stuff
like this was really cool and anyone at
any level can do it like you have user
groups around you that you can get
involved in another one you can get
involved in and stuff like this there
one knows these guys hey things are
podcast right don't that rocks is a
massive one okay so that is a great
podcast there are lots of other little
podcasts around as well things like pain
and pain it's run by a mate of mine
called Lars Clint if you want to talk on
a podcast let me know I'll put you in
touch with Lars get on a podcast it's a
little thing but it's just like that one
little step towards what could be a much
bigger thing in the future so stuff like
this is cool it's exposure again Stack
Overflow is another awesome one and what
I really like about Stack Overflow is is
again it's one of these things that
gives you this sort of history of what
I've done over time when I was
interviewing people if I could have
found someone on Stack Overflow and not
necessarily have like John skeet kind of
profile right but just have something
where I can see that this person was
actually asking questions about dotnet
five years ago and they said that
started it or answering questions or
just doing something and it's so simple
and my profile isn't particularly
fantastic I haven't answered or asked a
question in years but for a while there
it was something that I did and that
helps sort of build up that profile
again so that's cool projects personal
projects are another good one so this is
one that I started some years ago now
automated security analyzer phrase p.net
webs
and frankly this is kind of gone a bit
unloved lately because I've been busy
with other things but it was an
opportunity to build something put it
out there bunch of people used it and to
that point about leverage they said eyes
as Troy chose that guy who starts to
know a little bit about security stuff
builds the reputation helps with the MVP
things that kind of stuff much of the
reason why I don't do anything with this
one anymore is because they do a lot
with this one now this one I know most
people know I asked yesterday as like
half the audience and used it and then
toned not my fault I'm sorry and the
really interesting thing about this is
that this is literally something I built
in spare time in fact the first version
this I built was when I was with Pfizer
I was on a plane on the way to the
Philippines I thought hey this would be
a good idea and I had downtime in the
hotel there and I found the Adobe data
breach and a few others loaded it in of
thought our fumer makes a look at this
today about a hundred thousand people a
day use it 1.8 million subscribers
sometimes it has up to three million
visitors in a day and it's a hobby
project I built at home on Azure and all
of you have access to these technologies
so all of this stuff sort of just moves
you in that direction of having more
exposure and more profile and it's not
that I did it to try and get that it's
not like hey let's just do this so that
you can become a big name or something
it's because it was good fun and it
really helped me a lot doing what I was
doing at work as well a lot of the
reason I was doing this in fact I always
tell people half the reason didn't have
our been poned was I wanted a data
breach notification service the other
half was that I wanted to learn about is
Europe because I was starting to do a
lot of his EUR at work so all this stuff
so far has been very positive where
things start to take an interesting turn
is here what I've found over time is you
start to see as you get more and more
stuff out there is little cultural
nuances about the things that people
might be tolerant of and then the things
that surprise you about the way people
react about things you never would have
thought of and a play a five-second
video clip here I got some feedback on
after a conference you may not know it
but you
you've already been hacked thousands of
the attacks occurring each day you know
I play this and we go how do we know
he's a hacker he's got a hoodie and
there's a green screen haha everyone
loves it and I showed this around the
world I probably did 20 different talks
with this clip on it and I thought it
was always funny people always loved it
job well done and then one day I did
this talk and it was actually in
Brisbane so I was very close to home and
a bloke came up to me after the talk
and he said is something that he felt he
needed to talk to me about and I was I
was kind of curious about that okay I
was you know normally people come up and
say hey great talk I was like cool so
and he liked it and he says you know it
was a good talk but there was something
about the hacker and he was kind of
awkward about it like he didn't want to
he didn't want to sort of spit it out
and I'm like okay what have I done wrong
would you went to first let's try that
again
what have I done wrong so the hackers
black and I had to turn around I went
[__] was he oh yeah he was now what now
what I didn't realize of time well I
sort of didn't penny didn't drop at the
time was the bloke was American and he
was very conscious of the stereotype of
race and crime and I was showing a bloke
hacking someone who was black and this
made him concerned that maybe it was
perpetuating a negative stereotype and I
sort of thought about it later on I went
oh hang on a second
when I did this talk there was this guy
in there hills a hacker is this guy as a
hacker
this guy's a hacker this guy's a hacker
this one was also hacker a true story
this was actually a news article about
Russian hackers and this is apparently
what a Russian hacker looks like and
that that the penny that dropped from me
was not necessarily that I had done the
wrong thing but that I had put something
out there which was faced in the world
and there was a cultural tolerance which
was inconsistent with what we normally
had in Australia and I still the only
person who's ever come up and said hey
maybe you should sort of think about
this and I still do the same talk as
well and I'm gonna explain why in a
moment
but it's thought that was interesting
that there are these tolerances that can
be very different and when you put
yourself out there on sort of a global
platform you
going to get different views another
similar example is I wrote a blog post
that I put a lot of work into about
secure password reset features and a lot
of the that sort of premise of this was
things like when you allow someone to do
a password reset you want to avoid
enumeration risks so an enumeration risk
would be where you put an email address
into the password reset form and then it
comes back and says yes the counts
exists or no it doesn't because that
would tell you who has an account and
who does not and I wanted to try and
make the point that enumeration is more
of a problem on some classes of websites
than others so I put this image in I
cropped this very very carefully to
ensure that there was nothing in there
which you wouldn't see if you went to
any beach in Australia in Australia it's
warm enough to take you to top of anyone
so I was very very careful about I was
conscious of it I know the red bit here
there is no user registered at this
address and the whole point was on
something like an adult web site there
would be a greater expectation of
privacy because there's a social stigma
and I had several people contact me and
say I had this on my screen if my boss
had a walk past and seeing this I would
have been so much trouble okay this is
like one little image out of thousands
of words worth the blog post you know
like let's not lose context here but it
upset people in a way that I hadn't
anticipated so I end up changing the
blog post to put a little warning at the
top and said incidentally before you
scroll down further down the screen
there is going to be a cropped image
nothing you want to see the beach but if
that may offend you click here and it
will be replaced by photo of fluffy
bunnies the fluffy bunnies and not
wearing any clothes trust me it's there
you can go and check the post so hey I
did not see that coming one that I in
with the benefit of hindsight I probably
should have seen coming is when I wrote
about CloudFlare and this was in about
the middle of 2016 and this was about a
5,000 word blog post this was a really
big one that I thought made a lot of
really insightful points as part of this
blog post I wrote one sentence which
when you see it now you'll probably see
you saw the Geico war I could see where
someone might get upset I said I'd like
to solve world hunger poverty and get
rid of Trump but none of those things
are going to happen in one go okay maybe
Trump which I think most of us would say
is a perfectly reasonable thing in
Americans anyway after this 5,000 word
blog post which took me many many hours
to write some of these blog posts will
take a day or two a total effort they'll
happen over weeks a lot of work goes
into them and then they go up there for
free and I had feedback and someone said
the there was no kind of you know nice
blog post thank you this is really
useful it was like don't talk about
Trump well Hillary please refrain from
bringing it up here and someone else
chimed in you can take years to earn a
great reputation seconds to lose it it's
an off-color remark about Trump or
Clinton and then this person said a
small part of me died today this is real
the comments still there the sentence
about Trump is still there as well and
the reason the sentence about Trump is
still there is that the thing that
really dawned on me is that sometimes
it's okay if someone gets upset if
everyone gets upset not so good but
sometimes there's nothing wrong with
that
I've got a little clip from an Aussie
comedian called Steve Hughes and he
explains this beautifully political
correctness the oppression of our
intellectual movement so no one says
anything anymore in case somebody else
gets offended
I can be offended sticks and stones may
break my bones that's true again it's
not that I want to go out and upset
everyone like this is not the goal and I
think he gotta have a little bit of a
moral compass which knows when you're
crossing that line but that the penny
that that really sort of dropped the
thing that dawned on me was that if I
wasn't upsetting someone I really wasn't
trying hard enough you know like you who
become so bland and so boring and I
think all of us like to see that there's
a little bit of personality in the
things that we're reading and the people
that you see speaking here if it's bland
and vanilla and boring honestly like
it's just I don't know why they bother
so I'm getting increasingly comfortable
with the fact that when you put things
online there will be people out there
who will get upset some of them
admittedly get more upset than others I
had some a little while back decide to
create a wordpress blog all about how
much I suck the entire blog was
literally Troy hunt sucks dot
wordpress.com and he wrote many blog
posts about how much I suck and I am
actually a little bit disappointed that
it has since been deleted and I couldn't
find it on archive.org he put a lot of
genuine work into this he's discussed
account about how much I suck still
exist that's still there there is
literally disgust account
all about how much I suck and I kept
seeing this I'd see the WordPress blog
and I'd see the discuss account all
these things about how much I suck and I
thought I've got to hit this on the
front foot I have to go and register a
domain to establish how much I no longer
suck this is out there served over HTTPS
now you know how I said the thing about
leverage right like when you do
something multiplied over and over and
over again when I did this I was
conscious that something happens every
single time I register domain I have a
philosophical disagreement with paying
three dollars a year for who is privacy
you know where you've got to pay money
so that you're not in the directory and
it becomes like a big phone book so what
happens as a result is every time I
register domain I get calls from India
trying to sell me web development
services now I thought this is gonna be
good I'm going to record when these
people call me up and see how many times
I can get them to say Troy hunt sucks
[Music]
there are actually more than that
and I just like edited out the best ones
but I just found that amusing and I
shared and a lot of people online
thought I was very funny
recently ex fact since I did this talk
I've registered never gonna give you up
never gonna let you go I have a lot of
recordings because it's fun right it's
like a I felt a little bit better about
registering domains in but you know the
thing about abuse online is that the
stuff before is kind of mild but
sometimes it can actually get really
serious and you know this is something
that until I started doing this talk I
didn't really share publicly because I
didn't want to make
raishin worse and we can kind of go to
different ways here who wants to
censored version he wants the uncensored
version that's good because I've only
got an uncensored one I'll share a piece
of feedback I got a few years ago that
really did upset me and I think you see
why now I've sat on this for years I
have a special folder for abuse I got
some great stuff in there feel free to
take a photo and I would bring this out
every now and then normally when I was
with mates drinking beer and we'd all
just get pissed and laugh at it cause
it's kind of funny
and I brought it out again recently
because I just think it's it's
interesting now to look back at just how
vitriolic some people can be and again
let's be fair as well this is nothing
compared to what some other people get
particularly when you see what some
women get in a sustained fashion so as
much as this upset me it's certainly
much worse for other people in some
circumstances but you know I wanted to
share just to sort of give you a sense
of what can happen and honestly stuff
like this today really doesn't worry me
it's like mute blocked move on job done
to be honest most of the interactions I
have online are absolutely awesome and a
lot of that is due to Twitter so I
thought I'd share a few things here
because I think the way we use social
media and we connect with random
strangers can actually be really awesome
for our careers and the things we do in
our daily lives and one of the things
that I've really enjoyed especially when
I come to events like this not travel is
the number of people are mate who say I
want to take selfies and trust me I find
this weird not know like I wish you
wouldn't do it weird kind of way but
it's like this is awesome they want to
think your photo of me I say to my wife
it's like you know famous now don't you
yeah on the Internet
thank you for bringing me back down to
earth but this is cool and I've met all
of these people all the way around the
world who just want to catch up and say
hey look this is awesome stuff and to be
honest every single physical encounter I
have ever had with any one bar none
after meet him on the Internet has been
awesome and the stuff like the abuse
before is someone sitting in a hoodie in
a dungeon who never wants to come out
and see the light of day you never see
them no one has ever ever come up to me
face to face and said anything even
close to that might be interesting if
they did so yeah I look a really good
example is often when I travel to places
I'll say look I'm gonna be in Antwerp
for example does some random person I
have never met before want to go and
grab a coffee or something and when I
went to Antwerp this was earlier last
year I had a couple of people actually
say yes and I met one bloke at the train
station when I had a coffee I'd never
met him before it was a very nice guy
and I had another bloke this one down in
the corner I got Stein he's like you
know I'll show you around he took me out
of the tunnel under the river and showed
me a few different spots that I probably
wouldn't have found otherwise
he worked in security we had a few good
chats about that and then he said ah I
want to give you some of the world's
best beer and I was like yeah everyone
says that about their beer he's like no
no he'd have to and I looked at that
when I go home and this is the Westway
turn 12 and it's like it is constantly
right as it world's best beer you know
that's right because you're Belgian so
it is epically good there's not as much
left anymore but it was really really
good and this was just again sort of one
of these chance encounters where every
time I've done this have had really
positive experiences when I was here
last year actually someone said oh yeah
catch up I'll show around Westminster
Abbey I asked the same question you know
just over here and when I turned up I
was like this kids like 17 like okay
fine he is sure and he turned up and he
had his teacher with him as well he's
science teacher and they showed Lars
Clint and myself around Westminster
Abbey and showed us where they do a
little robotics and everything we just
had this epically cool time just cuz I
said look we're gonna turn up in some
random place and someone was watching
and we had a very nice experience from
it so honestly that the online
encounters are really positive and I
don't want to sort of put in
bent on that by showing you some of the
abuse stuff another thing that I find
tends to happen on social media
it comes after posting stuff like this
so we got a new car last year and the
engine sounds epic and I took a little
video of and I put it online as I love
the sound of this engines great v8 and
someone popped up and said they were
happy with that and I say this every now
then some of you might have seen me if
there's probably two weeks ago someone
said a similar thing it's like I follow
you for security stuff could you please
don't talk about anything else it's my
time line about and that the funny thing
about this is right after that someone
else chimed in you know and and this is
a thing like you're going to be
polarizing to some degree and frankly I
mean if the first bloke didn't like it
well okay now like there's like you
didn't like it I'm gonna tweet a bunch
of other stuff you will like and I made
the comment a couple of week ago it's
like if you don't like beer and beaches
you probably want to stop on Falls
unfollow me right now because there'll
be mostly security stuff and then
there'll be a few other things that are
actually a bit of my personality another
one sort of taught me an interesting
lesson I got a new laptop I've got one
of these yoga 9 tens and whether that
the laptop I thought there's just my own
curiosity I thought with a brand new
machine how much data does it need to
suck down from the internet just to
update all the service packs and patches
and everything so I plugged it in and I
had a look and in total it pulled down
12 gig of data and I thought holy [__]
12 gig like that's that's really
interesting maybe other people will find
this interesting as well so I created
this tweak and in brackets at the end I
said stats of Ayub ent which is ubiquity
ubiquity mate networking products and
I'd written a bit of stuff about
ubiquity before the reason I said is
that's why our ubian tea here is because
if I didn't say that people would have
said where'd you get your stats wrong
and so I will head them off at the pass
I will put all the information there
already and someone didn't like that
and I'm
look in the gun mate it's three words
it's not even what the post is about and
there was a little bit of me that kinda
went this would be a time where it's
perfectly reasonable to say you're a
[__] move on you know because that's
the way I was feeling at the time here
is frustrating so why be aggressive
about this our finale look we'll try
this differently so went back to him and
said that's fine you know maybe it's not
relevant to you maybe should filter it
out and just so he knew I wasn't trying
to be a little bit facetious or anything
like that I put a smiley face and then
the guy responded and I felt really
really good about myself as I handled
that well I don't know you know this is
cool but the thing that sort of struck
me about this and the lesson I wanted to
impart from it is that one of the great
things about social media is it's your
opportunity to demonstrate your
character and when I think back to those
times I was doing the interviews and I
was trying to figure out who is this
person that wants to come and work for
us and spend 40 hours a week in the
office how can I figure out what sort of
person they are now I would hope that as
I went to my social media profile and
saw the way I responded they go well
handle that that was pretty reasonable
but have a think about some of the
profiles you see online I would think
about the way some people react and
imagine you were going to be employing
them and you read some of the things
they say it could so easily go either
way and also want to be clear that this
is not about like why don't you
fabricate this persona and if you
fabricate it just right you'll look
awesome and people will hire you even
though you're a dick hahaha like that's
not it right it's that you need to be
organic and honest and all the rest of
it and if you can and it's a positive
thing well then that's going to work
very very well for you so moving forward
as I sort of start to get to the to the
exit from Pfizer and the exit from
corporate life there was one thing that
was increasingly happening was this and
I suspect many of you have been through
this before so most of us particularly
in Western countries
have had these phases where the company
has said we're going to start sending
work not just outsourcing but usually
offshoring as well and that the premise
files are had as I said look we got a
bunch of people in the organization like
this they make us money we also got a
all of us here they cost us money
you're an expense and I'm sure many of
you have heard this before because
you've probably been in the same
outsourcing sort of thing and that is a
very sort of demeaning experience where
all the indicators are saying look what
you do is not valuable enough and I'd
see this over and over again in so many
different things the organization did so
for example the Christmas party would
come up and they'd send the sales reps
here this is Hamilton Island
incidentally this is where you send all
the bad guys 200 years ago good luck
with that
thank you santé places like this and
it's very very nice here now the tech
folks got to go the local balls club
we got a $20 ahead budget which was
enough to buy about three beers I think
we got the bowling for free I don't know
actually because I remember seeing that
and go and this is [__] and I ended
up going to a conference dinner instead
and this was sort of that the constant
attitude of the organization you know
technology wasn't valued I was in a
place where the very thing that I'd
invested my entire life in was just not
an important thing to the organization
and then around about 2014 so at March
2014 I got a new boss and this boss was
in the Philippines I had the same boss
for about 13 years before that new boss
in the Philippines and that the
Philippines is a very hierarchical sort
of society like every time I went to the
Philippines they'd be like hi so Troy
welcome so Troy a bit like really
awkward but that is that is the way the
culture there is and I don't know if he
wanted me to call him Sir Gerard or not
I dunno it was never gonna happen but
clearly there was a different set of
social tolerances and
very early on in fact before I started
reporting I said I'm gonna go and speak
at code mania in New Zealand awesome
conference code mania and I'm gonna be
going there I'm gonna be doing my talk
these are the dates everyone's cool
sweet and happy and then he says I'd
like you to come to the Philippines to
go to a meeting and at the same time
code mania I said well I'm going to Co
mania and he said no no no I'd really
like you to go so look I'm gonna code
mania and I was actually taking my wife
we're gonna have a holiday afterwards
and he came back and he said only
priorities are coming literal words and
the email still have the email I have
the evidence and this was sort of on the
back of all the other stuff right it's
like the outsourcing and they go into
the bowls club and not the Hamilton
Island everything and just the clear
intent that technology was not valuable
and the very things that I stood for
weren't important and every day I'd go
into work and it was feeling like this
just let that sink in for a moment and I
decided that things had to change
I did go to the Philippines and I went
for most of the meeting and I left very
late got flights delayed got into
Auckland like 10 minutes trolls meant to
come on stage into a closing keynote and
it was just it just stressed the hell
out of me so when I came back from
holidays to look we got to get out of
here like a I'm just done I've got to go
and what I decided to do is every single
opportunity that came up to do pretty
much anything I just say yes to so who's
seen yes ma'am Jim Carrey all right so
this is a movie where he just start
saying yes to all this crazy [__] and
then all this amazing stuff happens as a
result and and this is what I felt like
and I remember really really clearly in
that phase feeling exactly like Jim
Carrey from this movie because I was
just going yes to everything and it was
it was nuts because it was absolutely
non-stop but I was just doing a huge
amount of blogging and speaking and
whatever else I could possibly
while still asleep doing my job one of
the things are saying yes to a lot was
plural sight so every chance I got to
write courses I'd be doing it and some
of you may know but the way Pluralsight
works for authors is royalty based so
you create a course it's all very
carefully managed and curated and peer
reviewed and everything you put it up
online and then when you guys watch it
we get tiny fractions of money and if
enough of you watch it they become big
fractions and I went so hard on
Pluralsight that by the end of 2014 I
was making more money from Pluralsight
and Pfizer so this is good this is nice
like now I can leave the job except the
problem was I was going to believe the
job but now I'd lose half my money
because you readjust to more money very
very easily and the other thing is my
boss hadn't really spoken to me for
about seven months as well after that
incident literally just wasn't talking
to me anymore which suited me quite well
because after nearly 14 years it's like
you got enough stuff to keep yourself
amused right
I'm busy other jobs to do so in a way it
was kind of like I got to get out of
here but the pressure is off just a
little bit you know what I really need
is a bit of a push bit of a push to make
me go and then the push kind of stuff to
Christmas early 2015
came back there's an invite a meeting
invite and just send updates and you're
looking at the attendees you know that
was a really interesting one why would
all these people be in the same I won Oh
interesting and I went to the meeting
and one of the ladies there she wasn't
most senior person in the room she was
crying so this is getting a lot more
interesting very quickly right now and
on the projector now my boss was on the
ear on the phone he was in the
Philippines some of his bosses on the
phone no HR or anything like that would
have some reason they weren't there and
I said he's your chart now and I think
they're around about 11 of us in the
room actually in total and then they
said here's your chart in the future and
looking at Gunn that one has names and
then that other one doesn't have any
names and it's got less boxes you know
like where are we going with this and
and you know like the insinuation was
clear but no one was saying and I
remember really clearly saying
we just cut the [__] and you make it
clear are you making rolls redundant
well maybe you could apply for this job
in Singapore no no look I'm quite okay
if you are but you know what's going to
happen and eventually that is what
happen they said okay a bunch of rolls
are gone in fact they got rid of four
different rolls
mine was one of them it was all people
who were in Australia which like the UK
on the global market is an expensive
place but looking after Asia which is a
cheap place so it kind of made sense but
it was better than being fired and the
interesting thing is there were people
in the room who had never planted this
who'd never been ready for this and now
quite upset and the thing that was
happening for me is that like the penny
was starting to drop us going hang on a
second redundancy redundancies and only
good things redundancy is not something
that you cry about now is it and when it
all boiled down in order to have a
redundancy they gave me nearly two years
worth of pay walk out the door it's like
here you go whoa so when I was pissed
off like six months ago if I had a
walked out I would have had a small
fraction of that and now you're saying
go not only that but this happened in
January was just after Christmas and
they said you know you've got a few
months so I had until April so I went
absolutely nuts on Pluralsight until it
was double fuzzy and I just hammered
away at Pluralsight hammering away
hammering away and the only reason all
the Pluralsight stuff was getting the
royalties was because of all the other
things that I did with the blog's and
the speaking and everything else and
then eventually in the middle of a point
2015 it was the last day and I left
Pfizer my wife and I had a little
celebration afterwards I don't remember
much about that night this is the only
remaining evidence drinking krug
straight out of the bottle it must have
been a good night actually it was that
and it was also Belgian beer as well
this for her part of my celebration and
that's kind of the way it all wrapped up
so since that time so since April 2015
it has all been independence and the
things that I've spoken about up until
this point we're all the things that I
then leverage in order to do what I do
now so now life is often traveling
around to places like here and in fact
in this shot this is Copenhagen and it
was in October before last
and the reason why I took this photo
which you know when you compare this
back to the beach with the wallaby and
the sort of life I was used to as a
rather different part of the world and I
was here on the other side of the world
and this is how I spent my son's
birthday so he was turning seven just
then from memory and it was like okay
FaceTime you know I'm on the absolute
wrong side of the world I can't be with
my family and that the thing that sort
of got me thinking about and this is
something that makes a lot of people
feel uncomfortable is the price that
we're all willing to put on our families
and people don't like hearing this
because they can hold my family's
priceless but you're all here
not with your families because we choose
to make these sacrifices we don't go to
the office every day because everything
is awesome and we'd rather be there
instead of with our husbands or wives or
children we do it because it's a
necessity and we make this choice the
whole way along and I made a lot of
choices to make a lot of sacrifices in
evenings and weekends and holidays for
years it was like literally spending as
much spare time as possible and trying
to balance that with family but wanting
to do the Pluralsight things and
everything else but now what it means
does everything sort of balances out so
you know very often I play a lot a lot
of tennis with the family and I can be
down here first thing in the morning
with my son having a hit of tennis not
being worried about the time that I've
got to get into the office or being on
the clock or having to deliver something
so that's swings and roundabouts right
kind of balances out but probably the
last thing on this which I think is
really important is that I've had a huge
amount of support for my wife as well so
this is Kylie's I mean icarly and all of
these things we do including me being
here now is something that we talk about
and we go well what should we do you
know we've got these things coming up if
I go here I'm gonna be away for two
weeks we gotta go to Oslo and Denmark
next week as well you know should I do
that does it make sense you know and
very often this is long play stuff to
like going to Congress the other day I
really wanted to stay home and sit in
the Sun I was getting warm that's nice I
didn't particularly want to go to the
other side of the world and I got
nothing fraught they don't pay you but
it's the long play and we had this
discussion I went this is actually kind
of really awesome for our creates
collectively because we both move
forward when I do things like
and you know I think that sort of the
last thing I'd answer that and this is
really relevant for all of you no matter
what stage you're at is it you got to
have a shared vision so if you have a
partner and you're sort of planning how
we're going to split our time how are we
going to prioritize you got to be on the
same wavelength and the people I see
around me who aren't on that same
wavelength have a hell of a struggle at
whatever level it is that they're living
life so on that final note thank you
very much I've got about five minutes
worth of time I saved for questions
anyone have any questions how did I get
fired how do you get fired I does anyone
have any suggestions about how to get
fired
I think getting fired would probably be
like the easiest thing the world I think
of a lot of ways I don't know that it
would be a good career move so there's
that we're done is easier also I'd never
know anyone and maybe there are people
in this room who have different
experiences never known anyone who's had
a redundancy not been really happy so
Kylie had a redundancy from her work as
well so she was very happy with that the
other people who are in the room with me
when the redundancies were handed out
some of them looked really stressed but
two of the people did much better out of
it than me because there are over 50 so
they got a much higher payer one of the
blokes didn't do as well he went out got
another job straight away no problem so
you know that the people who had sort of
that the skills to back up what it was
they were doing no problems at all and
when you get a redundant you got a big
buffer because I was thinking like I'm
gonna go and be independent now and I
don't know where the money's gonna go
like I know Pluralsight will do well but
that could drop off I don't know what's
gonna happen but the redundancy gives
you so much buffer anyway and even if
it's only three months three months is
still a lot of buffer - yes was it scary
to go freelance oh I think it would have
been scary if it had to happen two years
earlier even one year earlier it it
wasn't scary by then
primarily because a combination of the
fires redundancy in the Pearl site
royalty is meant that I didn't have to
worry about money so I wasn't going to
stress about that I think it would be
very scary with the wife and other two
little kids as well I'd be I could
easily see how I'd be stressed yeah so
the question here was the gentleman was
saying he specializes in software for
disability was a quick but is also
wanting to have a speaker career as your
speaker as well obviously and he's like
should I should I write in Dutch for my
local audience on my my sort of
disability front or write in English for
the international audience look you know
first of all when you started talking
about the thing with with the Dutch and
the disability I almost thought maybe
this is a place where where you become
the guy right like maybe you are the guy
who does disability in the Netherlands
and I know that that is a small slice of
the world but maybe that's a niche but
it does sound like a very very different
audience to the broader sort of
international group maybe just need to
blogs maybe you need to Twitter accounts
you know maybe you just split that up
because I think you risk polarizing
people because you saw in the in the
slide there like there was a guy who
really didn't like my car you know and
he was getting upset about that it's so
easy to polarize people just with one or
two things that don't fit what they
expect to see from you so maybe multiple
accountants yep
so what do I recommend to what sorry all
right
so how do I promote or how should you
promote your blog so yeah the thing to
remember is that when I started that
blog I would have had I think in the
hundreds of followers on Twitter I don't
know if it would have been thousands and
what ended up happening is it just took
a lot of time with very organic growth
before people saw stuff God interested
start following me on Twitter so to be
honest forever in a day the only way
I've ever sort of gotten my blog out
there is I eat it I put it on Facebook I
have I use if then if this then that
anyone is that ifttt.com where you can
look at an XML feed you can take that
and automatically publish it to say
LinkedIn you know stuff like that
so I get things to publish wherever I
possibly can and then some people see
and then over time your networks grow
and people share it and it look it took
years and years and years for me to get
any sort of traction you know I mean
people people sort of forget how recent
a lot of that was it has only been two
and a half years and so I've had
independence and it was probably five or
six years before anyone really paid any
any attention yes
all right so the question is what well I
was employed how much time did I devote
to blogging Pluralsight courses etc so
one of the things that that makes that
slightly difficult to answer is that as
when I was talking about these you and
the PowerShell stuff I tried to do as
much as I could for Pfizer which was
also stuff that I could use for my blog
and for my courses I mean I did a
Pluralsight course on a whole bunch of
it Europe has stuff now I wrote that
course whilst I was at fires are doing
as Europe has and learning that so I
leveraged it and I multiplied it by if I
had to sort of hazard a guess maybe I a
bridged like an hour a night and maybe
three hours a day on the weekend or
something which which seems like quite a
bit but look at herbs and flows right
but I think that the most important
thing and we probably should call it
here most important thing about all
there is to leverage it so you know try
and take what you're already doing and
apply it to that rather than having to
almost sort of sequentially use your
time as almost like my mind was just
going a sink as much as possible work
smart not hard excellent life to end on
thanks very much everyone
[Applause]